[Music]
attacking you I believe there was an
infant happens yeah so happened this day
work
we're having on board it might look good
for us because they can't say we are
places already stumble folk you do have
him on board
he's gonna come and say something that's
gonna refute us I'm gonna make us look
to what we are so the freedom of speech
that were advocating it's not going to
work in our favor
so I think it's better that we call this
off yeah so I believe this is exactly
right okay and I'm so happy that's
happened you know why because it shows
you these guys are hiding behind the
camouflage of freedom of speech I was
invited here today I was told exactly
temples free and it's your time you're
gonna go up there and speak and I
thought is gonna be reversed I'm gonna
get abused
maybe you canonical chapter I'm here I
thought [ __ ] you I'm giving please
respect the music you know what they
come to earth they stand up or lay our
scene no that's what happened today you
see if you're watching this you
genuinely understand the reality of
these people so when I say if Tommy
Robinson had to change in the snow to us
today is a reality and a little pixel of
what he wants to do so I just wanted to
speak then what happened
FLA came yeah and I wanted him I said
come here I actually went at all because
you guys are against terrorism it's not
me telling them all all kinds of
terrorism what happened he was in his
first he came and many starts saying
things against us the Hurlant abuse and
then afterwards they start get physical
from behind he stopped pushing me
you know got behind you start pushing
here
yeah what it shows us like he said no I
mean the other day this is maybe to do
with reading [ __ ]
it's nothing to do with democracy it's
nothing to do with the so-called British
values nothing is everything to do with
intolerance you know subjugated
minorities and tackling them physically
and not allowing them a free space to
express their ideas even though
[Music]
it's hypocrisy and you can see and I
heard everyone to send this video to
mainstream media of what happened today
and he wanted to march to Twitter on
offices why because they took the
platform he's done exactly the same
thing today to me you are not allowed to
fool you're not allowed to speak yeah
you have done exactly what tweeted it to
you and look at the hypocrisy you should
not watch to Twitter
you should watch against yourself and
today isn't fine example and I once
again had suicide and his mission
battery something I am so happy because
what happened today actions spoke louder
than words today
lesbians are spoken he we see so I found
everybody watch this
hey boy boy boy we buy them I was
invited to give a talk we've got a
checkbook once again I won't miss Opoku
see freedom speech speech this is what
we're talking about guys
wherever Tommy Robinson is violence
follows is that they were match made in
heaven yet
wherever Tom Robinson is violence is
there there you go it's clean hypocrisy
is there I was invited to your Georgia
so you kept the hypocrisy David nice
guys what's the event about worst event
about freedom of speech I was invited
you know allowed to talk you just
defeated the oh bloody purpose of the
event the whole bloody purpose look at
the hypocrisy freedom of speech for
everyone can I speak yes sure what time
templars free sorry cancelled you this
is what happened and you wanna watch the
recipe H if only what did the guy say
only for
[Music]
attacking you feel like someone liked
the idea
like VIP you guys are VIP how many
thousands of followers I mean - laughs
we have new VIP very very good